you've uh
recently been on uh glenn beck's program
yeah
and there was this kind of one of the
things you've talked about
is being able to have this conversation
i don't know if you would put it as a
type of conversation that was happening
outside the mainstream media
but a conversation that reaches across
different world views you're right
having a nuanced
or just like a respectful conversation
that's grounded in mutual
but we can't have the reality because
the main model is is
the center both left and right is in the
process of stealing all the wealth
that we built up and they've organized
the extremes
uh into two larping teams that i've
called magastan and wikistan
and then you have everybody who isn't
part of that complex
all seven of us the number of us who are
able to earn a living
looking at all of these mad people
playing this game
you know there's a phrase inside finance
when the investment banks
are trying to look at price action and
somebody says this doesn't make any
sense and somebody will say it's just
the locals stealing from each other
and that's really what we have we have
we've got the leaders of magastan and
wikistan
uh you know championing these two teams
is sponsored by the center
because it's a distraction while they
steal all the silver and cut the
paintings out of the frames
that's what we you and i are looking at
so when you ask me like do you have any
ideas about the abstraction for free
speech
i've never met mark zuckerberg i've
never met sunder
i i never met larry page i was once in a
room with sergey brin
i've never spoken to elon musk
i hang out with peter thiel but we have
a very deep relationship but i don't
really speak to me that many other
people at you know
sort of at this level
you